welcome to the Friday night livestream
yes
Friday night stream have the Monday
stream usually but why not go for a
stream on Friday I've got some dropped
frames I hope my connection is doing all
right
yeah let's see let's see what happens
I'm just going to start the show and
hope the technical side works well ok
there are some news I don't know if
anybody is around already yes I have got
some some guys around then users what is
what's the news we have a new emotes
yeah that's nice one you emote you can
only have one at the moment with the
current subscriber count but yeah it's a
it finally was approved by by twitch I
don't know what took them so long yes
yes this days the mode anyway the idea
for the show was to play some play some
games and I wonder I wonder if I
actually have Lee chest don't walk in
the title because I'm not showing up
there on the streamer page which is kind
of irritating
do I have to turn them on again what do
you want to turn on again folks here
twit weird
then I'm not on the on the front page
there anyway my idea was I wanted to
play some idiot it's me it retains me
quite a bit actually that I'm not
featured there oh no I am okay
I wondered yeah because of the titling
of the show okay anyway I wanted to play
some games today okay and folks I said
she's turned emo so I wanted to play
some games and I wanted to play a
somewhat longer time control no rapid
and something like 10 minutes roughly
per game so then it's a bit more relaxed
I can talk a little bit more about the
games and generally speaking has some
yeah chill out
end of this week if you define Friday at
the end of the week so let's get going
um what kind of game do I want
so we talking about standard real time
minutes 10 something like 10 + 2 F maybe
rate it and I don't care about the color
or is there actually way to play
tournament okay they've got a game
against I didn't Dalek um okay I'm going
to play default just mixing mixing
openings I play E for currently a lot
okay this is tempting actually let's do
it I play Evo a lot and try to try to
test my a form-based repertoire
Oh TCC is hosting my stream that's cool
so I'm going to take and the ephah
repertoire yes it's going to be released
on in almost precisely four weeks yeah I
know I hoped it would be quicker but it
is completed but I have to do the video
recording and I expect the whole thing
to have video of around 1012 hours maybe
yeah and this is quite a bit of quite a
bit yeah you have to make video on that
it's it's not not quickly done so it
will do or take a while we have the
title title will be will it be something
with keep it simple
yeah I expect 10 to 12 hours but it's
just like it's a rough estimate okay so
a Bishop e7 plate but I didn't Derek the
issue is that a winning upon Queen e2
would check and check winds upon he's
got this b7 attacked and d5 attacked and
he cannot cover them both it's the thing
97 I'm going to take on d5 and I know
it's yeah it's a lot of a lot of Queen
moves but it's it's a big setup on
and lots of arrows it's an arrow and
yeah while we edit I can't I can get
some tea I'm coming straight back for my
from a chess club and I had I took quite
a bit of tea with me but I didn't didn't
drink it not all of it so um let's have
a look here this is actually something
and I have to think about from wound if
I take on b7 night before is actually
quite an annoyance interesting
that's ten plus two templates - bit of a
relaxed time control this is rooibos
rooibos tea yeah so if I take b7 there
there is this night before move which
feels very irritating so how am I going
to handle this 95 maybe 95 not entirely
clear to me if this is is this is grade
maybe and Queen d6 I can actually take
on b7 so I'm going to do this it's a bit
wacky this line here maybe it's got a
six now now that I think of it
maybe a 6 ok 6 F word Queenie form yeah
lots of Queen moves
lots of Queen moose no did you see
already my second new teacup this is
really nice it has got all the flex not
all the Flex of the world but lots of
them would have been great in the ICC
days when we had flex 4 for them for the
players Queen takes b7 isn't that
working I think it is at stake be
settled yeah this it is pretty big F
it's zero point six liter sounds really
nice
and also what I've also got yeah and now
we are approaching the real cool stuff
I've got a new light in my office I
can't make it brighter or darker or
change the type of light cold light warm
light great right I have no idea how to
use that but you can you can adjust
things yeah I feel like I'm a much more
flexible now with the light a disco ball
to make it groovy I guess this is an
easy move at least I have to take this
the screen it's a check no no disco ball
no okey-dokey so here there's the threat
on c2 night a 3f I basically have to do
that
light request stroboscope legged thanks
for subscribing I know you've been
around in my mind my shows and videos
for a long time thanks for subscribing
so I'm a pawn up in this position and
there's not much in terms of
compensation I would think I would say
don't know black seems to be a pawn down
for not that much we should be 5 yeah
cool cool
in terms of if you guys like paper books
real traditional paper books the e4
repertoire that is now completed and
everything will almost certainly a mess
I'm saying like 90% also be released as
a traditional paper book it's not a 100
percent certainty but close to that
no not self-publishing it will be almost
certainly be released by a new HS okay I
can check here it will be up on chasuble
I think March 10 or 10 or 11 something
like that I think we are we're talking
four weeks
that book will be possible the paper
book here will be on Amazon but the
devil devil take a bit of time for sure
because the actual book to be
transferred into other the information
that I have to get into a paper book
form it's actually quite a bit a bit of
work it's a I mean I have the analysis I
have the text but when a real paper book
needs some needs stuff like the the the
what is called the diagrams the the the
vanilla pictures of the pictures of the
board and a little bit formatting and so
on it's it's a plane it's a lot of
additional work the title will be keep
it simple play before or something like
that something like that
okay so what's now I can take the five
that was the original idea and I think
I'm going to do it can take on a three
and somehow verse and my pawn structure
bits but it's not a big deal I hope when
he for Best Buy test sets also a good
title and you know what hooks here that
was suggested was one of those was one
of the suggested titles but I ultimately
did not
I ultimately did not like that title so
much because there are actually the
deads it's very clear that this is the
Hamiltons auspicious motto but there was
and there was in my repertoire there are
very few lines that Fisher actually
played and I didn't feel like we should
use Fisher as a marketing ploy when
there aren't many lines in there that
Fisher actually played it is bigger than
mercy for appetizers we have we're
getting close to 700 variations
hey the exchange French was used - no it
is it is actually the keep it simple
approach is it's used in the repertoire
but I mean you just need some hundred
lines you just need it but the thing is
I'm going for lines and this is this is
the key thing I'm going for lines that
that in case you forget the actual
recommendation and this is what's going
to happen all the time absolutely all
the time absolutely no matter how strong
you are you will forget stuff and in
this precise moment it's important that
the lines have a somewhat easy concept
and this was the idea so that that
simple means that they should be
relatively simple to remember but also
simple to play in a way no I did not see
caro vs magnus Snopes I've been to my
chess club so I have to check check
later looking forward to that I like to
watch chess960 sometimes I feel it's
difficult to play from him
so we see five I'm going to take the
rule and now see
I can go g-form
any sharp play in my four repertoire
gambits or something it is more more of
a sound and solid repertoire admittedly
there are I'm not sure there's again but
let's not gambit in there right from the
get-go there's actually no decent you
for base gambit anyway I don't know they
simply nothing I think we're you may
really sacrifice stuff so I'm going to
try to win this you know it tests the
Scotch gambit at the Scotch for Knights
things like that but I don't know really
good gambit lines with 1.e4 like let's
say a 45 there is no good game midline
there maybe maybe maybe you can go for
them for the Evans gambit yeah which is
it's not really good yeah but okay you
can try I'm I'm thinking maybe this is
this is this is this repertoire yeah
thanks for the game I did Dalek it's um
it's something I'm thinking about
definitely doing a repertoire that is
not in the keep it simple fashion but
but a sharp sharper repertoire I don't
think that there is zone let's see what
challenges do I have I've got a couple
of templates to yeah like I'm going to
play something like 10 plus 2 or 8 plus
3 or whatever something that's a bit bit
slower yeah this is
possible future project repertoires not
only keep it simple star but in the more
yeah make it complicated style like I
did with the Banco gambit for example
I'm thinking about as a future project
like black against one a form and
something sharp really sharp maybe 45
maybe 45 with black played in a sharp
way a let's say a Sriman gambit against
the the way or things like that
it's something that I think about but I
have not completely decided what what
I'm going to do next first off want to
finish this project and I'm really happy
with with the line selected I mean some
of those lines that feel yeah feel very
sound may be boring yeah you can win
many games I had the first my first
French exchange game with white and a
classical time control game last
Saturday in the Dutch league and I had a
winning position my move 20 and my
opponent wasn't bad and it was a 2001
feat of Master how in depth would si the
repertoire is it's I mean it's 700
variations in in in chasuble so I want
to guess roughly that it will be it
won't be a huge book at the end paper
book maybe 180 or 200 something like
that pages I have not thought about an e
45 repertoire yet folks yes
I don't even know what to make loudest I
have have no idea what that is okay III
buy actor oh I could do this yeah 94 94
cents an idea in those in those lines
anyway
should before I play the field master
rated 2270 or so that that was this game
that I did I mentioned and okay so what
is going on here I should avoid I'm
thinking if I can go g6 here looks a bit
it looks a bit weird maybe just be sure
to be 700c yeah the pond siani or the
McCloud yeah that that would be
something for a black repertoire but
against the Ponciano 3d5 I think is
quite good video how to refute the Trump
that won't work here Trump is a pretty
good opening I like to see five against
that front so what I looked at in my a
banker gambit repertoire and it is some
I think quite a good line yeah my idea
here is I'm attacking the d5 pawn and
see that I'm I have some chances to win
their porn actually for example
something like put this to see for
playing the night back and it's hard to
cover yeah good evening to the drunken
lawyer
yes I'm fine thanks for asking
I just returned from a chess club and
okay what's going on here okay I'll go
ahead was the idea
he's attacking be fab that I win d5 what
about car oh you mean what I recommend
against the car oh come in my repertoire
the two nights is my recommendation and
wasn't such a such an easy
recommendation I like the line but I
also liked the panel for a pen of
variation leads to very open piece
players think it's very helpful for many
players if five is a bit of a funky
choice but I think I try to isolate this
pawn in a way yeah I know it's a weird
position about this love this online is
a bit weird no I didn't have a training
session at my club just just played some
of off hand off hand is that right
casual blitz games okay I've said c4
first step and ask the Queen about his
plans
you mean the night on bah look it's
trapped yeah currently but you know you
have ideas Wow it's the weirdest error
ever you have ideas like this or this
it's not so bad okay in the game quit
default plate yeah and here you know
it's a quite interesting question
I could go III sorry II 6 this looks
like the most yeah
solid choice and take these six next
yeah that's what I'll do
I don't see how it keeps that I will
probably just trade or Whiteville trade
and then these sixes these six seems
gone they are those lines with an early
c5 they are always leading to quite non
symmetrical and here very non-standard
positions and this is the reason why it
is usually believed to be a good term a
good tribe to play for a win with with
the black pieces the situations are just
so non-standard that many white players
yeah get into trouble so let's see we do
a twenty six I don't think how he is
going to I don't see how it's going to
prevent it this is the way yes actually
mm-hmm so
[Music]
I can't go Bishop takes these six in
this position yeah I will do it's an
interesting question you buy great helm
or Jaime helm yeah do you think chess960
is a realistic alternative to normal
chess you know I think I mentioned that
on stream more than once they have kind
of mixed feelings about chess960 many
starting positions feel very awkward to
me and they sometimes I feel it to be
very unattractive type of chess on the
other hand you could argue that it is
still a completely over loop that this
was saying you can of course argue that
it is still worth exploring simply
because we get rid of all the all the
opening theory I would a pretty awful
blunder yeah and I just didn't see that
B 5 was hanging
I have to take and now that Paul is
hanging and yeah I would like to walk
him to his seven but there is a bishop
taxi form this one
that looks a bit yeah okay four is a
really weird move but me I kind of have
to the modern defense yeah there's
nothing particularly wrong with it to be
honest soand it is slightly risky and
some in some lines the modern but it is
a good way if you want to unbalance the
game and you want a type of game that is
generally non symmetrical I sometimes
for me sometimes these positions are a
bit too a bit too non-classical in the
modern but I have my share of experience
with it I've played one g6 a lot
actually when I was a kid a kid is
strong and like 18 19 20 this is this
kind of this kind of age
ah thanks for subscribing yeah a federal
a for looked almost for stay if I don't
want to lose upon Nia actor oh is
playing this rather well his idea is
probably to play f3 and make my night
look a little bit inconvenient or in or
inconvenience my night then see for
fields like it's falling a very strange
position very very strange I actually
was thinking about Luke 2 before which
is very weird again it makes everything
even more even more murky what a weird
game f3i move the knight is also Knight
to d6 which is an additional problem
[Music]
yeah a notice stupid peasant sure you
can just do a one-time donation it is on
my twitch da TV channel page it's of
course very welcome okay so if I've
played before
[Music]
Oh cforce hanging it's not nice it's not
nice
it looks completely weird completely
weird yes thanks for posting the link
she'll car I this is the one way to to
donate
I have not set up on every thanks for
the donation oh my gosh okay so I'm
going to go back I guess very very very
good game
yeah but actor oh I think it looks
really really good I think he can
actually take on C form because at the
end there is 96 Wow
haha thanks for the donation clash kids
99 I know you do you charge me at the
mode don't see you oh yeah yeah
let's see it now okay so ah what game
here what happens here after B 5 B 5
yeah I'm going to play it I'm just going
to play it and hope for the best
Night Moves a chick d6 and night xB 5 c4
hangs and I back into the game of is
there some some blunder did I blunder
stuff no ok I take this and then I can
take these six next the Knight b6 I
could take d6 yeah I think he didn't
play at that precisely now I'm getting
now I'm getting things under control
again yep
desperado which this one and now White
has the weirdest the realest oops oh how
do I get rid of that white has the white
has the weirdest pawn structure here
double a pawn double F pawn
the issues that the pawns are so weak
I'm going to win them most of them all
of them okay so how do we do this I need
to get the Knights into this game I'm
freeing this okay
yeah and actual lost on time yeah thanks
for the game actually you plead that
really excellently I think I wasn't big
trouble
I think round here yeah you lost the
threat it was a very bad position
yeah thanks good game okay so The Clash
kid let's play The Clash get five plus
five
okay so let's play the Schliemann and is
this only classical challenges
you mean like time control I wanted to
do something like with roughly 10
minutes chess yeah which is a little bit
less stressful I just kind of what I
wanted to have a somewhat shield way of
ending ending the week and also in the
Monday show last Monday we had this this
algebra it match with Carlsen and hence
I felt that was good to have like once
it's was quite entertaining see the
world champion play and it yeah it was
good to have in one show however it's
not really something that you want in
every in every single show of course
because it's just like a click fest and
you want to talk about the games a
little bit more you need a little bit of
more bit longer time no matter how
control so the clash kit has canceled
the normal way of playing this is Bishop
to c5
I know there's also d6 that also has
been played by strong players
oh that's 36
yeah I take the e pawn is too dangerous
I think there is like a rupee one I know
that this looks a little bit less active
but I feel this was played by people
like even sokoloff and okay I'm going to
pop this in the corner this is a
position that I actually like quite a
bit for blank the half-open F file gives
good I think gives good good chances
White has this idea to put a knight on
to d5 but it's not the end of the world
we can say the same for the F farm
oh okay so taking this or not but take
it give up very lightly take with the
pawn and that doesn't look good my night
I had to go back to it be a dad and that
doesn't look look correct I could just
go Bishop to e6 but not sure if that
helps
okay this this cannot be terrible let's
save but I'm also not super enthusiastic
now actually five I will just probably
like if he goes here I will just drop
back to g8 I guess the main point of
Bishop e6 is just that I can go Queen d7
Connect rooks and oh that is a
surprising choice alright Bishop didn't
look all that great you know okay I will
do this yeah Knight takes the ideas to
go night g6 and ultimately to f4
the only thing I'm wondering is if he
has Knight g5 after it good with a tempo
and then potentially F Falls yeah it's
not that's not great let's do it
[Music]
yes I'm playing viewers you can issue
issue a challenge man I have a lot you
have got 16 challenges and it should be
a little bit of a longer time like 10 10
10 something okay I'm I'm trying to get
a knight to f4 I keep this this this
would be great so I don't know ng6
sorry that was real necessary
yeah it's somewhat somewhat longer time
like 10 plus 2 or you can also do like
clash kit did 5 +5 some something like
that because I want to do a little bit
of a relaxed stream talk a bit more
about the games the mute button didn't
work really well Maya you still hear me
really why why that's really weird
hmm you know you know that's funny
that's funny
people wait
okay do you mean ha ha you know we don't
really wear the echo is coming from AHA
for some reason for some reason oh yes
no there's no echo now don't don't you
which echo why now as hell
the it is loud as hell you say maybe I
can do this wait maybe it's better now
maybe it was very very loud hmm maybe
it's better now
yeah then the mic in the notebook I
actually switched off I failed
okay that's really weird
I what I did is I turned off the
internal microphone okay I will check
this a little bit once this game is
completed yep no it shouldn't no there
shouldn't be the wrong mic active really
shouldn't be in fact if you hit my if
you hurt my my my sneezing then because
I muted my my my desktop microphone
definitely yeah I understand but you
don't have to tell me that the song was
better like every two seconds I will fix
it after after the game is finished I
came out player and look at the sound at
the same time then I don't really don't
really get where the issue is we'll see
yeah yeah I'm going to try to
trying to get something on the air foul
that it's this one and this is a move
you just play and if you think about it
then something is wrong
I have a couple of settings here early
this one maybe I don't need that even
mmm okay so I had to take this and that
should be a decisive attack rook g6 is
going to be killing and I won't play the
Latvian gambit okay thanks for the game
flash kit so let me check the settings
just for a moment I'm using OBS yeah and
has all kinds of settings I have three
external maybe I just disable everything
like here disabled disabled standard
maybe I just disable this that couldn't
make sense do you hear me now no we
don't hear me at all right the video
that's the video
the sound is great now you hear me okay
it doesn't it doesn't show anything you
know I I had some kind of I could see
that there is okay it's kind of weird
because before I had something um I had
something that like an equalizer you
know I saw that there was sound anyway
if it's good now it's good now and so
let's see who's challenging me it's a
really long list
is there anybody I haven't played before
maybe just for newbies anybody in the
chat there's a one zero no entity for
four maybe entity for four let's do that
five plus free yeah it's great to hear
that that you that you hear me fine it's
a bit strange
and now the desktop audio is showing but
not not my audio funny enough okay so
entity for for place the the same ish
variation of the nihms Oh
when you challenge do you see the stream
on Twitch as you played the opponent i
sorry I don't understand the question ah
I see yeah it's it's actually a tricky
question should you watch the stream
while you play me or any other streamer
um honestly
oh that was not a good move 94 the funny
thing happened in they got Tuesday
Tuesday exactly here Fiona had a stream
and she was playing as she was starting
a tournament I think it was a 3-0
tournament or yeah 3-0 tournament and I
actually am yeah I was around I was
waiting for a student to arrive and he
didn't he didn't show up and so well I
felt more what am I going to an air
joint the tournament and I was leading
in the tournament and I was just playing
and expecting the student to come so I
was basically ready to stop the
tournament every any given moment and
yeah anyway so I was just playing I
didn't listen to the stream I was
playing game of the game and I was
leading and then one point okay he
didn't show up and I decided to switch
on Fiona's stream and I listened to the
stream a little bit while playing my
games and then actually in the very
final round we got paired against one
another and it was really weird to play
I destined at the stream on
take back okay what way exactly is the
thing where do you want to take back
like here I'm not going to take
everything right now I'm sorry that
that's kind of silly I'm happy to accept
one one take banquet sorry yeah and okay
and the final game I was actually
playing while while watching listening
to the stream what are you doing now
letting the clock run down and it was
actually difficult it was actually quite
difficult - it kind of irritated me and
I've landed a piece and I don't know I
mean maybe I would have landed it anyway
but it was a bit bit a rec league game
at the end I I got a draw out of this
yeah I'm a full-piece up here against
entity 404 I ever felt that listening to
her stream was more irritating and than
anything while playing you got some some
additional information sort of but it
was kind of I lost focus a little bit
yeah that's not not very difficult
technique I mean I managed to screw up
quite a bit of those kind of positions
but here doesn't look very difficult
kid I'll get the King into the center a
guru create next and
195 is also a good way to end this
pinning situation all right you just
took it
what is really weird so that I don't see
any I mean I don't see the mic in terms
of this no I don't see the the audio in
a way and you hear it obviously but I
don't see it in the in the streaming
software
[Music]
yeah this is actually sometimes drawback
of an increment time control games can
can get really long at Toms okay thanks
a lot for playing entity 4/4 he resigned
so somebody said he is in the shed Lucas
or said Lucas the locals yeah you can
you can turn the material counting off
you can challenge me I won't challenge
anybody I okay you have charge me I
can't make a play on Nexus okay so locus
you should play rather soonish okay here
we go
it going good to play the three nights
I think it works using the desktop mic
what's the wing like icon for next to
the IG end I am that's true
yeah that's the folks early you could
still hear me really okay so the locus
is going for the Bishop c5 lines
alright I'm a threatening Knight takes
c6 ty winning a piece I do explain some
some chest you know okay black is
trading one d4 this is actually a line
that I get rather often
and why does in really good shape him
Queen g7 is often played or just Bishop
takes d4 but White has a nice position
the Queen on d4 is strong so here I
think Bishop to e2 is actually what is
in my repertoire that's something that I
had forgotten to be perfectly honest but
I think this is actually quite nice
Knight takes e4 there should be 95 okay
here have an easy solution just take on
c5 I wonder if if I have something
better than that
[Music]
the thing is if I take on c5 and TT
recaptures of course then black's pawn
structure is a little bit it's a little
bit devalue J with the double pawn but
but there is a problem
my knight is not great on c3 if he goes
c6 and he's got good pieces well I'm
going to take it still from a structure
point of view it is some it is some -
favourable let's say to not play even
though blacks some piece pieces are not
bad if he cancels we should be 658 it's
it's fairly ok ok so I can I don't need
to take a protector pawn I can I can I
can just castle if I want you cannot
take your form yeah I think I can do
that let's start with cancelling ninety
form I think won't work I can just take
something like Bishop f3 then rupee one
check yeah so I that was I expected him
to just cancel and now I'm not quite
sure what the best setup is I wonder if
this is good
the Queen would be nicely placed on a3
looking at the dark squares a little bit
but black it's okay he's got this idea
my pieces my pieces are not really all
that great yeah
here the bishop is not very active the
night is just passive I definitely need
to reorganize that okay the rook do you
one maybe yeah I think what you wanna
prevent any rooty for an endgame if we
trade all of them if we trade all the
pieces the King and pawn ending would be
very likely winning for white with the
four against three pawns the phone is
going just back so we f3 it would be the
standard choice let's do it
keep it simple decision cover you form
and then think about what to do next
group d8 and then we ate hmm not sure if
that was the the best possible decision
but black is definitely not doing badly
here I think it's so kind of okay but he
basically gifted me a temper with Luke
da da da droopy eight and this means now
I'm a bit quicker on datafile so I won
if I take with the Queen I'm going to
take control over the default rook takes
rook t8 okay this is fine
sorry a technical kind of game now but
it is just uncomfortable note that this
e for porn is taking away many many
important squares and so the queen is
going to c7 try to try to activate I
wonder this makes the clue that looks
good yeah if he Queen to b6 I play
Knight
a4 yeah this would just win the pawn and
Queen to a5 I have Knight to g5 oh but
that looks very wicked Anya Queen to d6
maybe Queen to d6 that's on paint 26 is
definitely definitely an idea Queen to
u3 is there the other
and for I don't know FY I didn't like so
much I wanted to keep this pawn chain
protected and f1 would weaken okay I'm
going to take a look at that we can pawn
a form an idea
now food I was night Knight to Queen to
b6 I don't know if that helped okay now
a fourth now at four I think he's
released the pressure a little bit of on
from before and and sometimes we'll be
able to play a five yeah yeah I thought
Knight e4 is just good but maybe I'm
wrong
Knight a for as Quinta f5 maybe
I can also I know it looks funny but not
be one that's just going to also not bad
I'm going to do it the night is easily
coming back into the game
so is trying to get back into the center
yes let's put this here
interesting interesting way of playing
here by the Lukas
okay I would definitely I definitely
need to need to protect you maybe
there's some f5 at the end Knight d5 is
also on the cards Oh interesting very
interesting huh okay
I didn't I did not really have this on
my radar and no I couldn't play the
rapid shield tournament yesterday I was
teaching the whole day
maybe I just take here yeah there are
some tournaments that I cannot play I
know this is from Chester comb and not
leeches but I haven't have not ever not
a single time played the title to
Tuesday and I really would have liked to
do so it's a cool tournament and I was
never I could never do it always always
had lessons okay so what's going on here
he's attacking a form
I don't don't not totally sure how to do
this g3 I'm going to cover that I could
have taken a poem f4 was hanging and
then my health position felt a little
bit loose oh my I completely missed that
shot move
unfortunately there is going to be six
coming
my wife that was bad really badly played
a g3 was an extremely bad move I didn't
I didn't see Bishop c2 at all huh
yeah Ruby wonders also looks bad it
looks pretty bad even a simple move like
Queen to be snap maybe even Queen to b6
is good weird yeah Bishop d3 Queen F to
Mary I'm worse no no question about it
I actually think I was I was doing very
okay somewhere around here white is
substantially better I think then I
screwed it up step by step Queen to e7
[Music]
king of Wonders Knight g4
[Music]
you know anyway
after 94 I can't resign of course I
actually ship takes t3m can I do this
Knight age - Kim G - Queen e1 Queen e1
Mookie one King takes age to look the
one at the end well
okay
that's a difficult move here Luke takes
the one you have to really think hard
about that
might be something else but I know root
the one
and this is someone using a pretty
pretty pretty some Sam I know and using
a smartphone or something okay it's a
bit of a bit of a waste of time
okay so where else can I come something
yeah well so cuz Nam
nassim okay let's do something else do
the other coins
that was a quick quick quick engine
marking no joke
okay yeah yeah better not playing people
with provisional writing app it's always
difficult to say because there might be
the autumn there might be the odd person
who would sign up here on D chest
because they see that I'm streaming on
the side and yeah and won the game okay
cousin cuz Naseem if I go here I'm this
going to be an issue yeah I definitely
played badly this game the game before
yeah good night to the stupid peasant
yeah okay but here you know here there
are a couple of tactical ideas the first
one is to just take on f2 Knight takes
King takes Queen f6 chick and then King
III has to be played
[Music]
Queen f6 immediately is also possible
yeah kid Knight f2 King takes Queen f6
King III
I don't know I don't know Queen f6
immediately is also an idea Queen to f6
Queen takes g4 Bishop takes d4
[Music]
I could go Queen h4 actually as well and
then g3 and then Queen f6 that could be
interesting let's do it I'm not entirely
sure what the most precise is but you
cannot take I don't know a couple of
minutes yeah okay Knight takes King
takes Queen f6 King III I mean I'm not
winning material immediately I think
it's an extremely strong attack for sure
but I'm not sure if that what would have
been the strongest option the idea here
is that after g3 I go Queen f6 and after
Queen g4 Bishop before Bishop d4 94 I
was threatening on C 2 and 9 f3 check so
my my point is that g3 is actually
weakening what maybe it is
so geez free and now I'm trying this
take default what now has to take on g4
then as a maid threat on f2 and and
divorce hanging so Queen takes G form
bishop deform bishop D 494 and then
again that's 92 and 93 check ideas I
really think it is quite good
you know I think he has to change on g4
what else is down Queen takes g4 looks
completely forced I'm a little bit I'm a
little bit surprised that he's taking
time on this as everything hangs and he
has to take on g4
let's to where there's more emphasis on
twitch recently money is certainly an
incentive for streaming on Twitch that's
that's absolutely true there are
possibilities better possibilities there
than on YouTube there are for donations
and and and things but for me personally
I have a different agenda I mean I also
like to earn some money with it and I
have to be that's clear but I have not
done oh wow this is just giving away
everything isn't it take it for me there
was was also a different thing and I
have not done much with my YouTube
channel for a long time like for a
couple of months at the end of 2017 I
didn't do much or anything at all I
didn't have that much time and I also
had a bit of a lack of motivation a
little bit it felt a bit stale doing the
same things and what I wanted to do is I
wanted to do something again in terms of
videos in terms of yeah interacting with
the chess community and I felt it's
better for me to do it in a live
environment than on then reproduce
videos simply because for me it's better
to have a some sort of schedule like
then let's say I have the Monday show
I'm going to show up there on that time
I have this time scheduled and this is
better for me to be like reliable in
introducing the content if I'm saying to
me okay I should produce a YouTube video
or two videos or three videos a week
then I do it like I have to I don't have
a fixed schedule there there was no real
that's a pressure
me to do it because yeah if six come up
that might so will be ignored
while I will not ignore some time that I
have put into my calendar like the
Monday show so yeah I got got another
material here against Castle awesome
thanks for the game so with the having
those those those times let's play
tinkle tunnels and the cheddar um with
having those scheduled times I know that
I'm going to actually show up and do
something yeah it's a little bit like
forcing yourself a little bit to to do
it because I mean I'd like to do it but
for me it's better to have a have a
fixed schedule if I'm just waiting
myself I should make videos it doesn't
it doesn't work to me all that well okay
I have a ninety a 3G three kind of
opening here with white this has been my
my main opening choice with white in
classical time control chess for ages
and it worked really well
I play various versions of 90s free g3c
four combined very successful with that
and then always has been an idea to to
do some content on with the English
repertoire based on once you for lots of
my variation that have plane over the
Bloch s have have been features already
but 9003 g3 is a bit a bit different of
course in some cases especially NIDA 3d
five can be quite different
okay here we have transposed down to a
mainline d4 opening them
Queens gambit Arash defense
Oh be six-month yeah be six as some it's
a bit dubious actually to go into a
hanging pawn scenario but you still have
to refute it I got that in tournament
chess earlier in early 2017 and I
couldn't convert this position even
though it was very good I think this
should be a force normal here
one idea for widest to play this the
bishop to b7 is neglecting the f5 square
a little bit
okay 95 would be the easiest it's good I
thanks for the cheer Lord Kinbote II is
that king bochi or King boater or what
is right there and how do you pronounce
that correctly I'm not there for sure
asked or says we miss more videos of my
series modern chess yeah I understand
rip King boat Kim boat from the x-files
okay so what's going on here if I now
take on d7 and the Queen takes and I
take on c5 and the pawn takes and I play
Knight f4 there's some stuff hanging the
question is you can also take
immediately I can take c5 simply 95 yeah
it is good yeah it's good no matter what
don't know what's best
yeah more videos of my series learn
chess yes I get your point what I'm
actually intending to do but I have to I
have to look at my schedule a little bit
and think and think about it but I would
like to do
one show weekly or every two weeks maybe
weekly I don't know where I'm actually
not playing games but rather would look
into early chess study and yeah show
some master game some strategic idea
whatever yeah so this is what I'm
thinking about
so it's possible a possible idea for a
new show the other thing that I was
thinking about as a format show format
is a show where you can send in
questions for positions let's say and I
will answer that during the during the
show so okay here I can win a pawn yeah
definitely Bishop f6 Bishop takes d5 and
I think I'm going to do it it's a bit
too too tempting to take
and nine takes v2 was saying of course I
would have liked to play the night on to
the into the center of it didn't work I
mean black has minimum let's say
compensation it's good that group the
two doesn't work because then ninety
four would be a pretty a pretty big fork
I think what makes blacks um yeah what
makes black some try for compensation
actually probably dubious or
insufficient let's say is that um I can
do this and this blocks this Bishop
pretty pretty clear name what did I
stumble into takes III rook takes pawn
takes Bishop takes that was a I should
have looked at this perform beforehand
yeah it can actually
something to check actually group takes
pawn takes Bishop takes King G group t2
okay so go into h1 the ship c1 will see
one Queen c6 check
Luke takes you three I think I have 95
I mean maybe something else does work as
well but 95 I think should win yep okay
this is a bit more interesting maybe so
Luke c2 is down normal move I'm not sure
if I'm playing as well I should probably
think about it a little bit more
this is probably to a doctor drunken
steed would spot that line in 0.20 two
seconds
yeah them the alertness form four quick
tactics is extremely tight with very
strong players so we got into that
monster walk again Wow
after all that say yeah thanks for the
game king of tangle so anybody on got
the Wii is the weirdest time controls so
Eric let's start
and I'm getting this back oops
oops yeah oh that's not good I can take
I have to now 194 both moves are
possible
yeah 94 this Bishop III so I'm going to
do this and it's probably stronger
yeah again after night before he had
Bishop III so this is the greedy option
just win a pawn or not
I can almost pre-move them in whatever
he plays even yeah yeah Queen should be
six doesn't help
I'll just take if he takes on g5
I actually don't take this but Queen b6
is made they are made in a couple of
moves this is also I almost made in a
couple of muscle I would still do it
Queen d4 Knight f3 wins the Queen III is
made so 94 has to be played and then
this is a pretty awkward pinned
pretty awkward pinned I just spotted
that after each five I should delete
this it's 95
mm maybe just detect them in the night
oops
just a ticket yeah and here a queen can
take me yeah my nighty it doesn't have
many squares that's definitely true I
can tick here first and then take be
true maybe why not the point I can't so
take me to how the Queen takes okay yeah
now Queen be true there is some rupee
one actually
okay
I can simply trade on deform I mean
not so thrilled about it it's always a
little bit age for is a little bit
annoying okay I'm doing this I'm not
super happy now do this
yeah night I could be true there was
rupee 1 and then Age 4 I don't know that
that didn't that didn't look very
convincing to me here I'm a pawn up
already so I don't need to yeah do
something super fancy some tips on
calculation it's not so easy to give a
like a simple and simple advice about
the subject which is actually really
white and important subject because
calculation mistakes are the most
frequent ones and costly ones can trying
to to develop with b6
and pressure needs to need to find some
someplace we should be for could be hate
I think should be fine
[Music]
I'm on to this pawn him in the next
couple of moves and then the pieces
start to make sense that's what I hope
at least I might be wrong and no no
that's not a position that you should
resign actually as white shouldn't still
not not so easy absolutely not yeah
calculation calculation is one of the
things and shares that is improved by
simply doing it all over again repeat
repeat repeat which is why I'm taking
this is why I am simply doing tactics
trainers doing the same doing positions
all over again solve puzzles this is
what improves it just by doing it all
over again
the more patterns you see and the more
[Music]
the more motifs you have seen the better
you get in the actual games it is just
what is this disregard calculation is
one of the things that is relatively
easy to improve when it gets to find out
what to actually do because you just
have to do it all over again that is
easy to do easy to find out what you
need to do but you still have to do it
- you know it's the equivalent of yeah
training for marathon I mean it's very
easy to do to do or find out what you
need to do to be successful in a
long-distance race you just have to run
long distances often and repeat and
repeat and repeat and the same thing is
with tactics and calculation but even
and this is the same thing as with
physical fitness even a small time daily
would help
it's a typical recommendation if you
just do like 20 or 30 minutes a day of
yeah a little bit of sporting activities
that you really helps a lot and with
doing combination it's the same no funny
animated gym II for ninety six ninety
three d five is not okay that's a pretty
awful version of our Scandinavian
okay so here I can check and take one
each for Bishop f5 at the end oh this is
a good move you can also do the tactic
puzzles without time limits it depends a
little bit maybe also under on the
circumstances how you do the tactics
training for example I did lots of
technical puzzles when I was still
working in the office job I was
commuting every every day by train and
often times the internet connection was
shaky so I did not I did not want to
have a time limit because it would
simply and sometimes kill the the
puzzles yeah because of disconnects and
this is my often did the non time limit
puzzles yeah thanks for the for the game
Eric okay so who else is on many many
people so anybody in the chat that I
could play and have not played yet
and I'm happily
I am okay it's six60
it's okay it's okay let's go I'm going
to play though no I don't think there's
a difference between Fisher random and
chess960 just just different names for
the same thing
[Music]
now what am I doing here pushing the
pawn is probably not so great I think my
Center is probably a bit overextended
yeah if I go in 597 it's going to be
difficult to maintain the center we
should be easier I know I can't go
Bishop d3 which would sacrifice the form
I really don't remember how it is played
this one I come on I just play move and
see what happens details before Queen
III is definitely okay again this is a
possible mainline
[Music]
yeah what did somewhat longer time
control make 6-0 is rather quick for
what I was thinking more like like if
you add the two figures like 10 so it's
not not so stressful let's him
yeah d takes d4 comes into consideration
I wanted to go Queen III then and take
afore next
you had the helloween gambit it's pretty
bad
yeah there's a small leg between the
stream and and the Chet or the stream at
the actually game there's a ten-second
like um yeah I think black should have
take only for us now he does the
Halloween gambit is bad but not if you
play it on Halloween
yeah I mean I understand if you're if
you are on Halloween we can consider
playing the opening just yeah for for
fun on that particular day but and then
that no good so um I took on d5 I'm
playing on the Bishop a advantage of
course but I was may have this is what I
was thinking I just spotted it and it's
a bit awkward and two pawns hang sorry
I'm a little bit late for me already
Magnus played the reversed hello win
with Jesus reuniting z4 yes but this is
a better version actually
[Music]
job
I have to play that I have to play well
this is pretty awkward because Bishop
before as possible
it's a good question should you watch
Magnus commenting on approach it
approaches League or Greg shadi was
holding us and it's a tough tough call
that's the thing I would go for for for
Magnus I mean I have seen that that pro
chesley extreme so I don't know that
would watch it again
Black is fine because my bishop is just
not well placed yeah the black is okay
definitely that there is a pretty awful
bishop I still think after Bishop c3
instead of rook c8 he should have
considered Bishop to b4
I think the Queens gambit accepted is a
pretty good opening yeah I've always
recommended but for four reasons I know
to me it is not it's not played all that
often especially on the amateur level
[Music]
the names of each defense and the
Colorado gambit am I going to say
everybody probably has seen that I lost
against the Colorado recently
Carano give me this I mean you know you
can the colorado gambit is some it's
just lost him like like just it's just
totally lost but it might not happen
that the opponent gets the refutation
correct and in a blitz game for example
which what happened to me somebody
played the colorado against me on the
chest twenty-four stream and it's
something where if you forget the
refutation then yeah then it's it's at
this murky that saying it's so bad for
like but it's murky and the circuits
it's a question if you want to want to
do something like that
if you play against someone who's 1000
rating points higher
there is no particularly good advice
just try to enjoin the enjoy the game
the the likelihood that you will score
is basically zero and it's just whenever
ever you do you will be the underdog
there is no fantastic recipe there 1000
is a bit much but if you play somebody
who is 2 or 300 points higher yeah then
then I have to think about this whole
moment then some strategy is important
and usually the strategy is to play
according to your abilities not try to
not try to do something what you never
do but rather play what you know I'm
trying now to get to the 6 pound average
ratings of my students is that it's a
wide range ready and why what exactly
does average mean you know I've got some
people with 2100 or slightly above and
[Music]
yeah it's it's a wide range
no I thought I would just jump here no I
have not developed an online exam I
don't know why why would that yeah to
establish the rating it's best to just
play real games okay yeah thanks for the
game funny and it made a gym on yeah
it's exactly the same very funny
animated gym to be also on on twitch
what gambits would I consider playable
in blitz yeah lots lots of fun gamba
documents and openings are playable in
blitz of course it was the bank oh of
course there you can play that also like
in tournament chess it's perfectly okay
opening moral gambit sure can also of
course play the the Evans gambit and so
on and blitz chest you can you can do
many things I don't I don't know if what
is strictly unplayable there at least
four forms for the odd game the London
system I don't play it's not really part
of my Robert - I have have laid it in
the odd game but very rarely so I get
the hello intimate okay yeah okay so
there are actually there's more than one
good line against it now G 6 is possible
I usually went for this
I usually went for this
this is one of the ways to play against
it and takes on 693 form it's actually
quite funny that if I would take with
this we were transpose into a scotch for
Knights I think Queen to e7 now
okay so if I just Castle now I will be
fine yeah let's do it
I mean I have to I will take that one or
two more and a games after that but then
I will definitely have to go to bed it's
really late already
okay so here I can take c3 and drop back
to the six male
and now white will probably take on this
heaven or b7 well okay black is a bit
better but it's nothing super special I
think the the Halloween if you want to
really refute it you have to apply 96
and an interesting line against the
ruler PES that is not very open or
tactical kind of closed with some active
pieces and kind of closed with some
active pieces it's not so easy to do
with the combination I think what is
quite interesting to take him I think
what is quite interesting is to play
something with d6 and G 6 for example 3
a6 Bishop a4 g6 scissor and somewhat
offbeat line that is still very playable
[Music]
laughs that's okay for white actually
that's kind of okay it's a bit a bit
it's a bit annoying here I would like to
play c6 of course but I don't think I
can maybe this first c6 there was too
much on the D foul
white might even just cancel long yeah
looks that's okay
yep expect him to cancel no I take my
bishop I know he might take be same but
yeah it should be sixes yeah it's two to
two man then white has played as well
let's see what he does he should be for
medium not really getting tired him I
probably will go for him to one more
game after this one but there I have to
call it quits it's just too late doesn't
tell if I'm yawning in the whole time
yeah I think this is funny yeah the
bishops here
okay so c6 keeping the the pawn
structure intact okay
so if I trade I'm actually helping him a
little bit with his pawns so I'm going
to avoid that for the moment taking on
default the idea is just to go route d8
maybe we should be 657 slowly trying to
build up on that I've ever have a
slightly better structure here with no
double pawn
not something where you would expect to
[Music]
to win with easily it's just a little
something but so it's it's something to
something to play for each wage five I
am not so sure about what he is doing
okay so if I double this okay
shouldn't double let's do this first
eight seven was saying look look
aah 2d 887 was all pre okay maybe that
wasn't a big deal actually take T one
okay
eight maybe yeah but this is fine this
is fine if he takes b6 I'm not unhappy
opening up the a Farland okay I had to
see what should go you should have six
maybe possible hey Bishop f6 maybe
he's stopping f2 then I don't know
doesn't look too bad oh let's see if I
can't trade it now white is played as
well I know it just goes for trading
everything down I came again opini
several actually I can pawn endings I
should be fine for me with my with my am
superior pawn structure why didn't i
snitch the pawn enough to worm I did not
see it could I take it I didn't see it
that's funny
okay so we got a Bishop ending and let's
see let's see about it
I need this these pawns I need on dark
squares so this
and b6 next
I can't
hitting I what's this
he's good at for actually f4
you have to chance them maybe it's
possible very much possible
poor
okay now this okay
he puts up quite a bit of points on
light squares yenna with g4 and so on
but yes this h7 porn that he can maybe
no not so much
he has to be careful he's low name
giving me chances trading I would lose
my youngest student that's easy turns 15
in a couple of days
okay before coming and I got the outside
person
I teach in German and English but with
oh what's that I don't want a bit stupid
what I did I've taken with the airport
huh
anyway yeah this is the wind now I think
to get this and then go to G form
yet the legend resides yeah thanks for
the game a legend um so we have Jeff
let's go Jeff you wanted to play some
sure what you wanted to play one of
those gambits right yeah I can go for
one or two more games so I can pre move
the Colorado right
Oh d6 really that looks weird
okay
yeah it looks a little bit weird yeah so
okay this is checked in too much looking
at this now and this is also not so easy
to meet okay if I play wait
d5 hangs
okay I need to get rid of the arrows
[Music]
just 93 anyway after I have to make a
move it's just six minutes here right
it's basically a blitz game
yes I'm the highest rated player and my
chess club but it's it's closed - cut -
we've got three I am so the two others
are similarly rated a little bit lower
but not much so what I'm doing is I'm
saying that c5 doesn't work due to
Bishop b5 and he cannot play the e pawn
because I'm on that lot and how do you
ever develop I'm also threatening a3 now
a three-night a6 should be 5 and that
wins the house
maybe see six maybe see six please yeah
yeah he heard it it's no he probably
didn't hear it but
yeah not so happy with us it didn't go
all that well
it still should be better for white I
mean make no mistake I mean I'm not so
didn't refute it super yeah super
convincing yet black still has issues if
I get like rupee one Bishop e6 black
cannot move really but it's so again it
was okay try this we should be six we
would win the Queen's I'm but he
definitely he will definitely avoid that
so we have Bishop him it should be five
I don't know let's do this develop okay
when whenever I have this kind of thing
against the King I always think about
this Bishop a six major F here Boden's
made where something takes on c6 and
then Bishop a6 made the e4 a patron
chess will will be released March 10
March 11 something like that the main
reason for this release date is the any
time to to record the videos
there are definitely loops play in a
bent a thorn type of event always fun I
wanted to play a four actually and now
think about this a little bit you know
it just doesn't make much sense get
Bishop d6 all the time and it makes nine
b5 a pretty stupid move if I cannot play
a four here okay there was a bit silly
yeah I'm really playing badly that's a
really badly played game might be fire
for my god come on let's focus I mean
I'm really stoned tired but I should not
lose this game by playing so stupidly
yeah the internet connection is okay
today try b4 b5 Black's play is simple
and now you can try to push the center
play h5 mmm yeah like it's really
comfortable to force open the be phone I
also try to play a little bit quicker so
that I might get a bit to be pressure on
the clock
okay so have two eggs it does and f3
isn't looking good
and queen h5 is playing great this game
great
yeah
[Music]
yep very nicely done by Jeff edits here
very nicely done
I really wanna I really play badly but
it was really strange I played pretty
pretty bad moves pretty bad moves yeah I
mean it's I'm really tired but so I
shouldn't play that badly I was a really
badly played game I mean considering
that white is probably winning to hear
something like this this is really tough
to believe that I'm not winning this
something I need to I want to quick
check here actually with the engine
because I don't believe this that I
shouldn't
because this is just very weird so here
a spoof loss
yeah I'm still okay on i-95 is this
ridiculous it's a ridiculous move the
engine actually says a four interesting
I was thinking when I was thinking is he
can take and do this as Luke a8 this
Bishop d6 and okay the engine gives
equal but this is actually winning for
Wyatt huh maybe I should have gone for
that I mean I was thinking we're just
going in this pay for I'd hope that it
works but I didn't see it that then I
can simply play the position here with I
saw that distant work but then I can
play just this as good
okay
yeah then if I go back and a p5 doesn't
make any sense Bishop d6 and now aged
six
all right I said see Froy is good for
while it's not rocket science I mean
this is something that something that I
probably would see in a in a time in a
in a real game let's say like like this
this is possible here I know I'm getting
completely smashed you know and I mean
I'm not doing this well but the position
is already bad yeah black has a very
strong center and I have I don't have
anything great Queeny to know it's bad
and Jeff played a very very good game
here I could have probably I should have
done better somehow in the opening
because that looks very shaky but I
didn't didn't see it so one more game
maybe is somebody on in the chat there
was somebody on soon in the chat who
wanted to play I think I would go for
one more game and then call it quits
it's really late as I mentioned there
anybody in the twitch chat that I
haven't played yet who would want to
gain Romagna on his Dramani an end
Marshwood loss vent himself awake like a
couple aha okay so who is waiting for
the longest time but that's
let's go was the first hint himself
maybe waiting for the longest time
[Music]
yeah it's tough I have to have to do do
it in some way okay ten minutes okay
[Music]
yeah thanks to them to the Father for
the follow Tony and oh this line I came
the Yeats variation of the flow swim
94 it's not a bad line at all yeah
Samuel is an idea but I don't know why
15 10 is if that sounds extremely
stressful for me
15 10 similar would probably would
probably be a little bit longer time
control simply father for me playing it
so yes I have played the pills not often
but I did
I mean maybe half a dozen games or
something like that yeah this looks like
I've winded deep on you can give the
player going for the cereal some extra
time that would definitely be necessary
then
yeah Churchill unpin ders ideally I
would like to pin him
and that's a question by Arsenal defend
when I was developing as a player did
aim to become titled early on no
actually not I wasn't really ever
thinking about a specific goal I just
played and think some things happened
let's say I never had a very specific
goal from the get-go like I never
thought about okay if I do this and that
I could become let's say this isn't that
raiding okay thanks for the game fent
himself that was a short game so maybe
we can we can do here Romagna and she
will know it's his no he's gone
huge loss and he's still on so let's do
those two games that is fair I think two
the two guys and then I'm calling it
quits
no I was just I was just doing things
step by step only thinking about
specific goals when I got near to it
like back then in in the day when I was
improving one one one thing that was
some and I was different to today very
different and is actually the the yellow
ratings back then they only started with
2200 so you could not have 2011 was just
not in existence there was just like
2200 and better and this is a big
difference of it to nowadays because
when I started out with chess I am
I pretty quickly my first rating that I
had was 1800 I never had anything lower
and from 1800 I got to 2000 quite
quickly and once you around 2000 2050 it
it gets to the point where you think
okay I should get an ero rating because
back then that was the next logical step
and once you got the yellow 2200 up you
automatically think about getting feet
master yeah because that my first year
Oh was 2280 I think I mean it has to be
above 2200 there wasn't anything else
and then there were just like 20 points
you have to to get to get to the FM so
that was the next logical step and so on
it was just a step by step process okay
I can check on d5 and I hope that helps
really I take on c3 there's rope shakes
maybe if I check yeah actually yeah good
lights to the drunken Noah a king of one
night c3 and then Queen f5
actually and then a working to give to
now actually in terms of like titles and
so on I had some other goals at the time
that that that I never that I never
managed actually because back then when
I was improving I always wanted to to
play in the German Junior Championships
and I never managed I never got down
[Music]
never qualified from my state
championships and the e4 chess
repertoire will be released early March
March 10 or march 11 hi I'm not sure we
had read on something like that
okay fatigue now and d4 yeah I started
really late in in those junior
competitions I only started playing at
age 13 so yeah and then I joined a club
and the first the first Junior
Championships that I could play was like
under back then we had under 17 only
under 15 I only played like half a year
so and then it was under 17 we had under
20 and under 17 at the time and you know
never got there
yeah thanks of the game ruthless and
harm on young yeah and the 79 I never
qualified under 20 I never qualified for
the for the for the German championships
didn't manage
I can't play my pet line against them
the English hoping for a quick sorry for
a quick short castling so that I can
push the H pawn yeah on my youtube
channel there is a video already that
announces the e4 repertoire it is from
late December and I basically tell you
what I'm doing what I'm recommending
there
yeah I'm sorry it's been a long day it's
almost 2 a.m. here no nothing comes to
mind
as no fan Ritchie asked if i if there's
any single discovery that would that i
could attribute to a significant
improvement like this kind of wow
moments no not really nothing that comes
to mind immediately
huh isn't this giving me c4 I think I'm
taking this unprotected
[Music]
no I don't this is some really a bit
weird
I don't really dream ever about chess
positions or chess tournaments or
something like that it doesn't really
happen which is a bit surprising
probably but I had it doesn't happen to
me so it's not like it never happened
but it's not something that happens
frequently okay so why just castles I
can improve slightly yeah but what worth
in null as if it is a good idea to
exchange Queens early on if they have to
capture with a king and cannot castle
anymore this is um I know it's the
typically annoying answer but it really
depends on the position there are
actually quite a bit
there are many lines where such a queen
trait is absolutely harmless yeah
absolutely harmless and I think there
are more lines where it is harmless
then where is dangerous but there are
some lines where the Queen trade is
dangerous and annoying so it's it's
tough to give a general answer them yeah
I'm honest with you I have a very simple
plan with the pawn up I just trade trade
the house just trade everything it's
right to win in the ending
the pieces of my pieces are not very
active so I have to improve this next c5
so that I can actually get a possum
okay so c5 it activates my bishop yeah
thanks for the game also Jeff when
you're welcome so it takes bishop cakes
no night it was stupid I would hang it
to actually I mean be takes Bishop takes
94 my bishop hangs well it interesting
if I go here isn't that a good move like
if he takes this before with a fork well
no I'm threatening to take maybe here
that that that looks a little bit like
him tricked himself a little bit damn
now if he takes here I go before and
fork is two pieces there yeah I think he
tricked himself them
okay just recapture and and this focus
in effect
yeah thanks for the game Romagna
I don't know chess in book just some
study using books it is still a main
main thing but of course there are there
are many video tutorials of course so
I'm not sure you'd be your thing we have
we we have we have both things
coexisting also I think in some ways
books are still very suitable to - for
chess because the real improvement comes
from just thinking about the positions
very actively and not just to watch them
on a screen oftentimes if you watch your
video it's like it's very much
consumption but you're not thinking
about it so actively and if you want to
think about it more actively off in a
book assist it's a good way to do it him
to put it on the put it on the board or
enter it into a computer and just like
take the time to look through everything
ok I hope you enjoyed the stream I'm
going to close shop now after almost
three hours and it's really deep in the
night 2 a.m. thanks for watching I'll be
back on Monday for sure the Monday night
show at 11 in the evening Central Europe
in time and maybe I will also do
something on Sunday but they will see
what happens
I'm also on by the way tomorrow evening
by the way for the ICC's similar master
I'm going to post something on my
youtube channel they are linking it to
the ICC's youtube channel so on that
will happy
that will happen tomorrow evening and
probably still something on my channel
Sunday let's I'm not quite sure but it
might happen very likely would happen
thanks for watching bye bye